considera la ecuación diferencial la
derivada de 10 con respecto a x igual a
2 x menos en los ejes siguientes esboza
un campo dependientes a los seis puntos
indicados para la ecuación diferencial
dada y los puedes ver aquí tenemos 1 2 3
4 5 6 puntos así que qué te parece si
hacemos una tabla por aquí voy a hacer
una tabla por aquí para ver cuáles son
las pendientes en cada uno de los puntos
así que voy a poner tres columnas en la
primera columna voy a poner x después
voy a poner otra columna por acá en
segunda columna voy a poner bien y en mi
tercera columna voy a poner la derivada
de james con respecto a x y bueno eso
sabemos que es igual a 2x
- y ahora qué te parece si empezamos con
el primer punto con este de aquí si
observas en este punto x vale 1 y
llévale 2 x vale 1 y llévale 2 y
entonces la derivada de ye con respecto
a x sería dos por uno menos dos lo cual
es igual a cero
entonces la derivada a 10 0 y quiero
dibujar una recta que indique la
pendiente en ese punto entonces vamos a
dibujar una recta que tenga una
pendiente de 0 se va a ver más o menos
así es una recta horizontal y ahora nos
vamos a ir al siguiente punto es de aquí
donde tenemos que x vale 0 0 y llévale 2
entonces me quedaría
por 0 2 lo cual es igual a menos 2 muy
bien entonces en este punto como se va a
ver una pendiente de menos 2 bueno para
partir desde arriba a la izquierda hasta
abajo a la derecha y va a estar un poco
inclinada entonces se va a ver más o
menos así aquí tengo una pendiente de
menos 2 más o menos así y ahora vamos al
siguiente punto este de aquí en donde x
vale 1 y james también vale 1 entonces
lo que daría dos por uno menos dos que
es igual a uno y entonces voy a dibujar
una pendiente de uno que es una
pendiente más o menos así está inclinada
a unos 45 grados más o menos se ve algo
así esta sería una pendiente de 1 muy
bien vamos al siguiente punto este de
aquí donde x vale cero y llévale uno
0 y llévale 1 y me quedaría 2 por 0 y a
esto le quitamos 1 y esto va a ser igual
a menos 1 entonces como dibujamos una
pendiente de menos 1 bueno pues va a ser
una pendiente que también va de arriba a
la izquierda hasta abajo a la derecha
pero va a ser un poco menos inclinada
que ésta va a tener también una
inclinación de 45 grados y se va a ver
más o menos así más o menos así observa
que está menos inclinada que está
pendiente de menos 2 muy bien ahora
vayamos al siguiente punto que es este
de aquí donde x vale 1 y menos 11 y jane
menos 1 y entonces me voy a tomar 2 x 1
menos -1 y cuantos esto bueno esto es lo
mismo que en dos más uno es 3
entonces como dibujo una pendiente de 3
es una pendiente que va a ir hacia
arriba pero que va a ser muy inclinada
mucho más inclinada que ésta entonces me
voy a tomar una
más o menos así iba a ser muy inclinada
y ahora vamos a ir al último punto donde
x vale 0 y 10 menos 1 x vale cero menos
uno y me quedarían dos por cero menos
menos uno lo cual me va a dar una
pendiente de uno entonces va a tener
esta misma pendiente
voy a dibujar o voy a intentar dibujar
una recta paralela tenemos una pendiente
de 45 grados y se va a ver más o menos
así aquí ya tengo de nuevo una pendiente
de 1 así que con esto ya está ya tengo
el inciso a perfecto así que vamos a
trabajar ahora con el inciso b y para
eso voy a bajar un poco en la pantalla
vamos a bajar la pantalla y vamos a
hacer este inciso b dice encuentra la
segunda derivada de ella con respecto a
x en ambas veces en términos de xy de
gemma determinar la concavidad de todas
las soluciones de la ecuación diferencia
en dada en el segundo
justifica tu respuesta bueno pues lo
primero que voy a hacer es recordar
cuánto valía la derivada de james con
respecto a x y nosotros ya sabemos que
es lo mismo que 2x menos y es lo que me
dice el problema y ahora lo que quiero
hacer es tomarme la derivada con
respecto a x de esto que tengo aquí así
que me voy a tomar la derivada con
respecto a x de ambos lados de esta
parte y también de esta parte la
derivada con respecto a x también de
esta parte y así voy a obtener la
segunda derivada de ella con respecto a
x y entonces que me va a quedar bueno
del lado izquierdo justo me queda la
segunda derivada de esto con respecto a
x esto con respecto a x ambas veces y
ahora del lado derecho que me queda
bueno pues voy a tomar la derivada de
cada uno de estos dos y me va a quedar
la derivada con
x de 2 x bueno eso es simplemente 2 y la
derivada con respecto a x de menor james
bueno pues eso es menos la derivada de
james con respecto a x con respecto a x
muy bien pero ojo nos piden la segunda
derivada de y con respecto a x en
términos de x y de jeff y aquí lo tengo
en términos de una constante y de la
primera derivada así que qué te parece
si sustituimos nuestra primera derivada
aquí y así vamos a obtener la expresión
en términos de x de ella no va a quedar
lo siguiente me va a quedar
2 - y aquí tengo la derivada de que con
respecto a x pero eso ya sabemos que es
2x menos 10 así que voy a sustituir eso
aquí 2 x menos
esto me va a quedar igual a 2 - 2x ma
ying-jeou racing ya tengo la segunda
derivada de ya con respecto a x en
términos de x de yen y esta es la mitad
del inciso b de lujo porque después dice
determinar la concavidad de todas las
soluciones de la ecuación diferencia
alta da en el segundo cuadrante
justifica tu respuesta y es que recuerda
si aquí tenemos unos ejes coordinados
estos son mis ejes coordinados este va a
ser mi eje gem y este va a ser mi eje x
y bueno entonces este de aquí sería mi
primer cuadrante este de aquí sería mi
segundo cuadrante este de aquí sería mi
tercer cuadrante y este es mi cuarto
cuadrante
ahora que sabemos de todas las equis que
viven en el segundo cuadrante bueno
sabemos que aquí todas las equis son
menores que 0 lo voy a poner que x es
menor que cero y que sabemos de todas
las que viven en este segundo cuadrante
bueno pues todas las que viven en este
segundo cuadrante son mayores que cero
así que déjenme anotarlo en el cuadrante
número dos
grande número dos en el segundo
cuadrante todas las equis van a ser
negativas entonces dejemos escribiendo x
es menor que cero y además se cumplen
que todas las leyes son positivas así
que todas las 10 son más grandes que 0
entonces qué va a pasar si nos fijamos
en dos menos 2 x ma jin
bueno pues observa lo siguiente es de
aquí es siempre positivo es 2 ahora este
de aquí menos 2x observa que también va
a ser siempre positivo porque si tengo a
menos 2 y lo multiplicó por algo el
negativo es me va a dar siempre un
número positivo y es de aquí también es
positivo es justo lo que me dice acá
arriba entonces eso quiere decir que en
el segundo cuadrante la segunda derivada
con respecto a x va a ser siempre
positiva porque voy a tener
que es siempre positivo -2 por algo que
es siempre negativo más algo positivo
entonces tengo algo positivo más algo
positivo más algo positivo nos va a dar
siempre algo positivo déjame escribirlo
esto implica que en el segundo cuadrante
la segunda derivada de james con
respecto a x ambas veces va a ser
siempre positiva esto sin duda y que
significa bueno significa que la
pendiente está creciendo en ese
intervalo lo que significa que tenemos
una concavidad hacia arriba y déjame
notarlo en este caso tenemos una
concavidad
una concavidad hacia arriba
arriba y bueno si ya olvidaste qué
significa tener una concavidad hacia
arriba o hacia abajo
vamos a recordarlo si dibujo aquí los
dos tipos de concavidad es tengo esta de
aquí y esta de aquí qué va a pasar con
cada una de ellas bueno en este primer
caso observa que la pendiente está
cambiando y se está volviendo cada vez
más positiva eso quiere decir que la
segunda derivada es positiva y entonces
tenemos una concavidad hacia arriba lo
podemos ver aquí la pendiente observa
que se está volviendo más positiva y
entonces está creciendo y se mantiene
creciendo creciendo creciendo creciendo
y en este caso tenemos una segunda
derivada negativa porque observa que en
este caso la pendiente estaría
decreciendo y entonces tenemos una
concavidad hacia abajo y ahora voy a
borrar todo esto porque estoy seguro que
no queremos entregar el examen a p con
todas estas notas
de lujo ya está completo el inciso b